so it gives me great pleasure to
introduce dr. Elizabeth Blackburn who is
the Morris first Dean professor of
biology and physiology in the Department
of biochemistry and biophysics
at the University of California San
Francisco she became interested in the
ends of chromosomes at a very early time
during her career and is now a leader in
the area of telomere and telomerase
research dr. Blackburn discovered the
molecular nature of telomeres and the
ribonucleoprotein enzyme telomerase
Blackburn and her research team
continued to work in a number of number
of model systems in human cells with the
goal of understanding telomerase and
telomere biology including how telomeres
are maintained and the consequences of
telomere loss Blackburn earned her BSC
and MSC degrees from the University of
Melbourne and Australia and her PhD from
the University of Cambridge in England
and for the younger members of the
audience especially our postdocs you
might not know that dr. Blackburn did
her postdoctoral research here at Yale
in the department of molecular and
cellular biology and she did this in the
lab of Joseph gall throughout her career
Blackburn has been honoured by her peers
as the recipient of many awards she
served as president of the American
Society for cell biology she was elected
to the National Academy of Sciences and
she was elected to the American Academy
of Arts and Sciences the Royal Society
of London and the American Association
for the Advancement of science and she's
currently serving as president of the
American Association for cancer research
she received the prestigious Albert
Albert Lasker medical research award and
she is also the note the North American
laureate for the Loreal UNESCO for women
in science in 2009 dr. Blackburn was
awarded the Nobel Prize in Physiology or
medicine we look forward to your talk
thank you it's a very great pleasure to
be here and to take part in this
wonderful symposium and and it brings me
pleasure to be back at Yale I
periodically come back here and and
visit but I was a postdoc over on
Science Hill but I used to go back and
forth between Times Hill in the medical
school because I had wonderful
scientific and collaborators and people
I used to interact with like Jones sites
and on Winer and many others here in the
medical school so I have very very fond
memories of Yale's medical school from
that very formative postdoctoral period
and which which as as was mentioned
really got me onto the topic that has
become kind of the interest in passion
that remains in in my life and so what
I'm going to do is to take you through a
little bit of the the journey and which
as I said in my title is going to be
from basic science to something I never
dreamed I would be interested in but now
becoming more and more interested in and
that's questions of how this kind of
science bears on issues of human health
and disease in ways that I will talk
about so what I want to do is first of
all give you to get us all on the same
page in terms of some some basics of
telomeres and their maintenance and
where we got to where we are now and
then take you through a little bit of
basic science story because I'm going to
make a point in that is that the basic
science really is crucial for
understanding the kinds of processes
that we've become interested in humans
and that is processes that do relate to
human health and disease so first of all
telomeres are the ends of chromosomes
they kept the ends of chromosomes and
were recognized by started genetic
studies in the 1930s as being very
important for capping off protecting
chromosomes in ways that were very
different from if a chromosome was
broken in which case such a break would
be subject to all sorts of instabilities
that could lead to genomic instabilities
of various kinds so as I said we're
going to go from basic science to human
health and disease so so what was the
basic science that brought me into
question of telomeres will the molecular
nature wasn't really known in the 1970s
at all but what was known was that there
was a big outstanding mystery about DNA
replication so the DNA replication
machinery had been understood by the
work of Arthur Kornberg and others and
it was known how this machinery worked
and there was a inbuilt mystery which
was extricated nicely by Jim Watson and
also fire not leak off in the 70s and
that was that the DNA a linear DNA
couldn't be completely replicated by the
known DNA replication machinery so this
was a problem right because every time a
DNA replicated as cells continue to
divide it was predicted from the known
machinery to get progressively shorter
and shorter and shorter and shorter
clearly a non-sustainable situation and
love McCarthyism said well maybe this
could lead to observations that had been
seen in cells and culture by and by by
various groups but you know senescence
has been seen in Encounters and so the
hayflick limit of this idea was
something that logic of thought or maybe
maybe maybe it could be related to
telomeres prescient idea and it turned
out that that that is very likely right
I mean there's every evidence if that's
right
but the molecular nature of what was
going on in telomeres just wasn't known
so I had the great good fortune as with
mention to joining Joe galls lab and Joe
was a master at finding good biological
systems basic science systems to study
fundamental questions and what he'd
found was the tetrahymena thermophilus
a harmless ciliated single-celled
protozoan that lives in pond scum in
fact that organism has very very short
chromosomes a whole set of very short
chromosomes they haven't carry ribosomal
RNA genes but they have an abundance of
these and it gave us a molecular handled
to pull out you know pull out
chromosomes and analyze them directly
and for the younger ones in the audience
DNA cloning hadn't really been invented
then it was just starting so you see you
know you had to get chromosomes that you
could get your hands on and so this
marvelous system provided those and what
we found was that there were simply
repeated sequences at the ends of
chromosomes as simple repeats over and
over and over again so how did they get
there and to cut a long story short
my graduate student Carol Greider and I
found subsequently at the University of
California Berkeley when I moved to my
own lab where there was the tenth row
homeowner and it turns out most other
eukaryotes had in it an enzyme that had
the capability of elongating the DNA at
the end of a chromosome so I'm now
showing you the very end has an
overhanging single-stranded region and
it could add single triphosphates G gtp
to GDP in this case to the end and
elongate the end of the chromosome
making the DNA longer so here was
something that could elongate DNA and we
had this problem which is that DNA was
predicted to be shortened so it could
this be this solution so the answer came
by using Tetrahymena again and amusing
the observation the Tetrahymena is
actually an immortal organism in other
words if you feed it talk to it nicely
it will keep on multiplying just
indefinitely vegetatively doesn't need
to go through sex or anything like that
just keeps on multiplying so here we had
Tetrahymena and i've had you know
apparently enough telomerase because
it's telomeres were maintained at some
length or other now we were very
fortunate in finding in that telomerase
enzyme that I showed you in this slide
here but didn't tell you that it has an
RNA component which is a very unusual
kind of thing because what it did was
work David Baltimore's and how Timmons
reverse transcriptase does but this was
an essential enzyme for cells not from a
retrovirus or a retro impose on what it
does is it copies DNA from RNA you know
breaking the central dogma of DNA RNA to
protein so this is an interesting little
RNA it actually has much more in it than
this sequence here and the RNA in the
protein core are essential for the
enzymatic action of telomerase
so we fortuitously came across a
mutation just in the RNA a single point
mutation in the RNA that we knew is the
telomerase component and when we
introduced that and ablated the normal
telomerase we found that the telomeres
progressively shortened and after about
20 to 25 cell divisions the cells ceased
dividing so we could really sort of
strike at the heart of the viability of
these cells by
just making their telomerase not work by
changing a known component of telomerase
so basically the the answer which then
has become very general for many many
ourselves in most eukaryotes was if you
had an immortal cell type and the
mutated telomerase such that you
crippled its ability to add telomeric
DNA and somatically to the ends now this
became quote mortal with this sort of
delay as the telomeres ran down and that
general idea under pins then generally
the kinds of things that have been found
in a whole lot of different settings so
we could conclude from that that in fact
telomerase was maintaining telomeres and
I must add parenthetically we had to
make up a name and people in my lab you
know we also came up with ideas for the
name but we came up with the word
telomerase and I'm very proud to say
it's in the Webster's dictionary now and
where do they're a few years ago so so
you know I can die happy because I've
added a word to the dictionary so anyway
so that's telomerase and it does you
know the job in vivo that we could see
it doing from these initial in vitro
activities now why do I doesn't what
does it matter to have this kind of
telomeric structure in essence what you
have at the ends of chromosomes as I
mentioned in the case of tetrahymena is
very general throughout most eukaryotes
with a few fascinating exceptions like
Drosophila for example but by and large
that's a derived situation when it
really does occur most organisms have
this kind of thing at the end
simple repeated quite often gee rich DNA
sequence on one strand with overhanging
single-stranded region that gets
extended by telomerase now what's the
point of this region well you know
partly it's sort of a buffer you can
shorten it down and in humans at some
few thousand bases long depending on
various circumstances they'll go into
much more in the latter part of the talk
but the important point of the sequence
is to provide a kind of molecular
scaffold that provides high affinity
binding sites for a whole suite of
protective proteins and the job of these
proteins is to form this sort of very
dynamic but protective sheath and that
is what makes the telomere
this combination of these proteins and
that DNA so without going through a lot
of the details over the years our lab
and many other labs have learned a lot
about the proteins and their dynamic
regular to properties and and one of the
things these do is to self regulate the
telomeres in this marvelously
homeostatic make sort of clever way
which is when the telomeres are long
enough this complex doesn't let
telomerase act on it and then when the
telomeres get shorter telomerase now
starts to see this insists structure as
different and short enough that it then
utilizes that DNA in this sorter than
usual telomere as a substrate and
elongates it so it's very a lot of
wonderful self back self feedback at the
level of the individual telomeres
themselves and as you can imagine this
is under exquisite control and and in
yeast alone over 350 gene products are
known to regulate this maintenance of
this you know make it longer shorter
change the length distributions and so
forth
not just telomerase genes themselves so
it's very explicitly regulated cells
clearly think it's important to protect
their chromosome ends now what happens
then if you don't have telomerase well I
said what happens in in the case of of
tetrahymena and and as I said this
generalizes and so what one finds in a
lot of human cells is that the
telomerase is rather lower than is able
to maintain chromosome ends and so as
these cells keep dividing they are prone
to this process here okay and this
signal which happens when a telomere
gets Charlotte shorter than it should
still has repeats and promote
chromosomal proteins protective proteins
but when it's too short and cells have
exquisitely responsive to this it sends
a signal and then the pathways are known
and known kinase azar involved in known
DNA damaged pathways and some pathways
are involved in this but it sends a
signal to a cell which if it's a normal
cell typically will tell the cell don't
divide anymore until the cell sits there
in its senescence state still
metabolically alive if it's a normal
cell in most cases but it poses this the
senescence right and so the idea was
then well well could this be you know
rather like you know a candle burning
down sort of thing if this is the
analogy with the candle mouths that
telomere and you know it so burns down
like a fuse get to this point here you
see it at the cellular level you know
could this be happening at the
organismal level and I'll return to that
in the last part of the most most of my
talk but first of all go through some
basic science questions okay so this
kind of system has been studied in all
sorts of organisms and of course the
budding yeast system has been a
marvelous system for all sorts of
branches of fundamental biology
molecular biological and genetic your
possibilities exist in this wonderful
experimental system and so um yeast is a
little bit like Tetrahymena or you know
like a stem cell
it's got large replicative capability it
can keep on multiplying as a population
and it has adequate telomerase and so
yeast has been studied a lot so let me
just tell you you know the basics and
then some interesting new unexpected
things that we are finding in yeast
which I think are very important as we
keep in mind what might be going on in
human cells so if you put these cells
onto a plate and you streak them out and
you speak for single colonies in these
nice robust white dots at a single
colonies of yeast growing on a plate and
this telomeres are continually being
maintained by telomerase action to
plenty of telomerase action
now if you genetically oblate the
telomerase the telomeres start to
progressively shorten just as I showed
you before and that gets shorter and
shorter and then they get to a point
where the cells will now no longer be
able to grow this and s/m cells so it's
a basically a g2m arrest characteristic
of serious DNA damage and then a very
low that real subpopulation of cells can
arise population about frequency are
about 10 to the minus 4 per cell per
generation and much higher than
mutagenic frequent
see but what happens is that these cells
then can maintain their telomeres by
patching them together by recombination
and Vikki Lundblad first discovered this
in the early 1990s and we found it in a
couple of different yeast species and
this kind of thing also happens
sometimes in certain settings in human
cancer cells have mentioned that later
but the point is that you know basically
the vast majority of cells will go
through senescence and this thing
rescues things and then they can do
pretty well after this but you know it's
only a relatively low frequency so
basically yeast cells do need their
telomerase but there is a survival
rescue that can happen at low
frequencies okay so this is well well
studied and so everybody thought all the
action happened around here right so
these cells appeared to be growing well
but we had some clues that maybe maybe
things might not be quite so normal at
this early stage so this is what I want
to tell you that's new so the idea
wasn't nothing that happened nothing
they've been nothing happened and then
suddenly also there since all hell
breaks loose okay but people hadn't
looked okay colonies are okay but they
don't really tell you much and so we
collaborated very recently with
marvelous colleague in our department
who's a physicist Harley and his
colleagues John Waihee and what we did
was utilized a great system they had for
looking at yeast mother cells now yeast
when they divide divided by budding and
mother cells had this very interesting
phenomenon which is that they're an
individual mother buds and forms a
daughter who then becomes a mother when
she birds right but the individual
mothers can only bud for a certain
number of times so so how is studying
this and we thought wouldn't it be
interesting to look and see what goes on
with telomeres here because everyone
said all the telomeres have nothing to
do with this so but that the tools
hadn't been available but how has this
great system and I'm going to show you
sort of a poor man's movie you sit down
the yeast cells either with streptavidin
in a micro fluidics chamber and then you
can look at individual worms lots and
lots of them under the microscope follow
them you know by taking movies every you
know a few minutes for a few days so you
mobilize the mother cell streptavidin or
you can put a little post in the chamber
down and stick her down and then she
birds right so poor man's movie but then
there's a hydrodynamic flow because they
flow liquid through the chamber and they
just wash away the buds right so she
just keeps on budding and you just see
all of this until she finally stops now
you can depict this data in the
following way so this will be a little
unfamiliar and I'll walk you through
this each one of these upward bars is a
mother cell and each one of these white
horizontal bars records the moment when
she buttered right and so we're going
through time up here this axis is time
and so you see this is just a typical
population of wild-type cells and you
put them down
most mother cells are relatively young
and now here they are bud bud bud bud
bud bud bud and then they stop budding
right and so what happens is that
usually the last cycle is the very
longest cycle the rest tend to be rather
even in length although there's some
unevenness occasionally as they get
older but by and large they just keep on
budding and then they they ceased about
and that's called mother cell aging and
a lot of genetics has been done on what
makes aging longer and shorter but no
one who thought telling me has had
anything to do with this so so here they
are
etc and now let's look at a cell and
then and then this final stop okay now
let's look at a cell which in which we
made a point mutation that simply
catalytically inactivates telomerase and
I put them side-by-side and you can
right away see you can kind of ignore
the colors but just have a look surface
all you see that there's much much less
you know they stopped
much earlier and and now we look at the
young mothers and we say what about
their budding cycles so let's blow those
two regions up here's the wild-type is
the bottom part etcetera and here's the
for this first ten hours or so here's
the mutants which have this point
mutation that simply inactivated their
telomerase and now let now ignore the
colors the colors were just you know it
doesn't matter just look at the
intervals and I think what you can see
is there's right away a lot of
heterogeneity you see a lot of much more
prolonged cell cycles but these are
really young mothers they've still got
many divisions to go and so we've been
looking at this are we looking at the
genetic properties of this and what's
going on is the kind of interesting
surveillance cells are scrutinizing
their telomere maintenance status and
they're saying something wrong there's
something wrong okay I'll keep dividing
there's something wrong something wrong
sometimes they go to a normal cycle
sometimes they have a longer one shorter
longer but they're really really
worrying all the time to the point where
their telomeres run down and they just
you know really get a signal to cease
dividing so this is that a real surprise
here and we're looking at the genetic
dependencies of this and the subsets of
the DNA damage and response and
signaling pathways involved and so forth
okay but I just wanted to make that
point this was you know it's not all
over you think you know it all and then
you realize that there's it's not all
over now the other interesting thing I
want to mention again in yeast just to
show you know the basic science that you
can do in these model systems I think
it's really invaluable for telling you
things that you you know didn't suspect
and you really wouldn't be able to study
easily in more complex organisms but you
can then start thinking well how do
those play out another thing that
happens we found in the genome-wide
response to deletion of telomerase so
what happens when you delete telomerase
well basically if you look up here and
this is they this is two independent
replicates of an experiment two strange
just to show that it's reproducible so
you don't need to look at one but
basically what happens is the telomeres
shown in the seven but get progressively
shorter the cells go into senescence
and then as I said those cells come out
and now they quickly take over the
population and they grow robustly and
they have these very long telomeres as
you see by this longer thing being
maintained by recombination now they
shortened down but the population is
growing robustly because they can always
do enough recombination some a few cells
drop out but they grow robustly with
these much longer telomeres
but they don't have telomerase and so
what we see as we look at gene
expression profiling which we did some
years ago in collaboration with Joe
Teresa at UCSF was that not you know few
things happen earlier and and we're now
looking much more given those very new
results that I just mentioned that cells
actually are scrutinizing the telomere
maintenance states right from the get-go
as the telomeres are shortening well
before senescence
but accident at senescence a lot of
things happen okay and we've profiled
all these and showed that it they fall
into a couple of classes and one is a
classic DNA damage response and
really what you would expect because
this do you know the havoc that happens
is these telomeres get uncapped and all
sorts of instabilities happen and then
these cells grow out now they're growing
robustly but look at this you can see
sustained very strong expression of a
number of genes and what would these
genes they were very interesting class
it was a class that had been
characterized to David Botstein and Pat
Brown's lab and it was what's called an
environmental stress response and you
get this common signature of these genes
being robustly turned on in this
response to a whole variety of different
environmental insults so what we're
doing was no not insulting these cells
externally but inside they are telomeres
are being maintained by this other
mechanism which apparently is allowing
robust growth that these are really
hurting inside these cells
you know they look stoic on the outside
but they're really in pain inside and
and they're telling us this in a very
strong population strong way something
is wrong okay
so cells that are supposed to have
telomerase in them and can be maintained
apparently robustly are still
physiologically very distinct from those
who are maintained by for what in this
cell type is evolved to be a
constitutively telomerase positives
sitting okay so now what about in humans
so now I'm going to switch to two humans
but just I wanted to sort of keep those
things generally in mind because clearly
we're going to have to understand a lot
about what goes on in humans and in
humans essentially telomerase has two
very different kinds of implications for
cell maintenance depending upon the
cellular context and I'll divide them
into cancer promoting and normal cell
replenishment situations so as I
mentioned in many normal cells there's
apparently insufficient telomerase
particularly the fully differentiated
cell types that they are subject to
going through into you know senescence
and so the question would be in well you
know what was what was the consequence
of this for the organism you could see
cells had loads of llamas you could see
in culture the tila moose would run down
but nobody for
quite a while but now there's much more
information for quite a while it
actually was not clear how this would
actually play out in humans because
remember in humans there are various
cell types and essentially what's known
is is summarized briefly here matters
that in normal human cells are the cells
that expected to have long replicated
lifespans like germ cells like certain
stem cells and then stem cell lineages
and so on you would expect telomerase
and indeed you do find it to be quite
you know robust and obviously in terms
of lineages okay now it was thought by
initial studies to be just absent from
fully differentiated cells of many
different kinds again people had not
looked enough and if you look carefully
and quantitatively you can clearly see
that telomerase is actually present in a
variety of cells previously thought to
be some telomerase negative you know
such as cells that have been
particularly useful for studies in
humans and that is cells of the
peripheral immune system you know white
blood cells right these are cells you
can get from the body from all sorts of
you know different cohorts of people and
you can ask questions about those and it
turns out that they're giving a very
useful window but these are cells that
are we always check this out carefully
they're resting ourselves and mostly
lymphocytes that you can look at other
types like granulocytes now so that's in
the normal cells now in this very
different setting of cancer cells
telomerase very typically is is actually
by the time cancers have advanced to
malignancy or progressed far telomerase
gets very very high and so in the
setting of cancer cells and I'm really
going to just pass over the cancer cell
setting very briefly here but I just
need to put everything in context here
the cancer cell situation is such that
in very you know typically advanced or
malignant cancers telomerase it promotes
cancer and and so what happens and this
is an oversimplified version the normal
situation here it goes on but if you
have in carcinogenesis some sort of
growth dysregulation telomeres are
shortening too much and then somehow to
lama race afro frequently gets up rate
and then telomeres get maintained now
I've collapsed a lot of research from a
lot of labs into this over
simplification here but the bottom line
is that the end result is what I just
said
you typically see in the Communist human
cancers particularly they're
particularly derived ones you know
robust telomerase activity there are
some exceptions and interestingly there
they're interesting classes they're
mesenchymal II derived cancers somewhat
rare but important cancers and they use
the equivalent of that recombination
based telomerase negative pathway that I
showed you risk these yeast cells so
there is another pathway but human
cancers you know given the preference so
to speak they really really like to up
regulate their telomerase and so a lot
of work has gone into trying to
understand what that does and of course
it does what you might expect it allows
these cells to have a prolonged
replicative capability which as you can
imagine is is important for the
advancement of the cancer but in
addition it's seeming and I just don't
have time to talk about this but it's
seeming that telomerase itself may be
also active in other regulation of
signaling of pathways that are important
to cancer cells and interestingly enough
pathways that are important for stemness
of cells so there's very interesting
biology starting to come up above the
surface about telomerase in addition to
its well-known day job of maintaining
telomeres by adding DNA to the ends but
the telomerase core protein is a big
highly conserved protein with much more
than a reverse transcriptase domain in
it and so there's going to be
interesting emerging stories there
that's really all I have to say about
the telomere and telomerase situation in
cancer cells but just to you know it's
not all over by any means and so now the
question is what about in normal cells
and so that's what I'm going to devote
the rest of this talk to discussing so
in normal cells telomerase is actually
good news and so now we're talking about
cells that have all their checkpoints
intact and respond properly to
signals from you know tissues and
signals around them normal cells so
what's the situation there well in
normal cells as I said there seems to be
not a lot of telomerase and is that
important for life processes so now as I
said telomerase is quantifiable in
normal cells I'd like to just show you a
specific example of some of the data for
this because this distance will make the
point that the very low telomerase you
find doesn't look random it looks pretty
pretty regulated and so what I've shown
you is pretty complicated here but what
this is is a QQ plot and we're plotting
the levels of telomerase in wresting
peripheral lymphocytes and we've sorted
them from the blood and there's two
different cohorts here and I'll tell you
what these cohorts of people are but the
point is that I'm gonna make is that the
patterns of different samples are very
similar across these two different
cohorts what I've done is plotted this
is the white line here's in the cd4 cell
cd4 positive cells I just plotted them
against each other in this QQ plot here
and then I plotted that against our cd8
20 cd28 purse and cd28 - which is the
yellow here respective magenta and the
yellow here and then they are aqua is
the B cells now this cohort is a study
I'll tell you more about but these are
basically postmenopausal women and
actually and and their controls who are
either caregiving of a dementia patient
who's a family member or not a long term
stressful situation and you see the
pattern here when you just look at the
sample here this is a very very
different cohort here and essentially
these are people they hiv-positive but
they haven't got AIDS
they're being watched like hawks at San
Francisco General and being monitored
extremely carefully but they hadn't gone
on to any medication yet but they were
being watched carefully the point is
that the patterns are really really
similar in terms of these relationships
of these cells and in fact that's rather
similar for telomere lengths but
interestingly in an individual it seems
as if the regulation sort of these
different cell types kind of goes up and
down as a group from individual person
to individual person and that's lucky
because in fact a lot of what is being
done in
such studies as these large cohort
studies that look at telomere lengths is
to do what you can do in a sort of
practical way with with samples which is
to get blood where you essentially look
at populations of blood cells so even
though we know blood cells sort in two
subclasses you can sort of forget for
the moment in part at least you know
what what I just said about these
differentials between subtypes because
what seems to happen is as a group we
see telomere lengths being regulated in
an individual person rather systemically
you know together and even buccal cells
and blood cells have rather similar
telomere length distributions within
individuals compared with between okay
so in these clinical studies that how
first of all give you a very brief
overview of what what is looked at
typically is just white blood cell
telomere length okay you know either
peripheral blood mononuclear cells you
know or leukocyte fractions or something
like that what you get is this
relationship so now let's look at the
overall pattern here because this I
think has become really quite
thought-provoking and that is major
common diseases particularly those that
get higher and higher in frequency with
aging and including cancers they've been
linked to shorter telomeres in normal
cells and most studies as I said are
using an immune system cells now just to
give you the sampling here what we see
is a variety of different and rather
common diseases or situations are the
risk factors of diseases that
particularly are diseases of aging but
which of course are very important in
their quantitative overall impact and
this is truly an incomplete listing here
but I just want to give you the idea
that this kind of pattern is just
showing up over and over again in cohort
after cohort at very different sorts of
studies and so on so it's a pattern we
simply cannot afford to ignore and
basically the telomere shortness goes up
with risk of these clearing common
diseases okay here's one example just a
relatively recent one you know this was
looking at a variety of cancers in about
900 people and basically the
shortness then predicted cancer the
incidents and also mortality in this
group so you know here's this
quantitative relationship here and so
just let me put this into perspective so
here's his does let's think about the
United States alone and cancer which is
only one of those diseases where one
sees as I said this quantitative
relationship but just to give you
specifics so the cancer for example very
frequent in the population you know look
at the numbers of cases one and a half
million just in 2010 you know over half
a million deaths in 2010 and the age
distribution orbit is very striking
because it's obviously age related most
cases are diagnosed after age 60 and so
that number is very important given
what's happening demographically again
I'm just showing in the US but here's mm
here's 2030 fraction of people over 65
you know do the math it's very clear
that as the demographics are showing
more and more aging these diseases of
aging are going to become more and more
of a large impact so what might be going
on in humans so I just want to sort of
step back and say well what might be the
new answers here
you know we where there's a bit of
trauma raised in normal cells that we're
looking at just by sampling the
convenience of blood cells we know there
are stem cells that have more telomerase
we know that seems to be fairly systemic
regulation of telomerase and telomere
lengths so what are the sort of
situations you might expect well if we
had a stem cell population we would
expect and germ cell population we do
expect you know telomere maintenance is
is pretty well maintained there'll be
some nuances but basically you know the
telomere situation is maintained so that
if addition by telomerase primarily and
shortening which is this incomplete
replication and also it's been found by
a by a number of groups some nucleases
munching away at the ends they more or
less in balance over time right now the
balance can go the other way as Richard
Hodes showed several years ago in in B
cells in the germinal centers and in
fact telomerase is up regulated in those
cells as they go through this go through
the germinal centers and
you see telomeres actually growing you
know in adults so it's not a rule that
telomeres always have to get shorter and
I'll get more back to that point and
then but let's say the other way around
if the balance is tipped in oops I
forgot to balance at that look the other
way then in fact telomeres will be a
little bit shorter you know eventually
if you don't have enough to llama race
and eventually get senescence and then
if the balance is tipped even further
down then in other words you know we
have even less telomerase perhaps no
telomerase then you know correspondingly
all other things being equal which of
course they won't always be but just in
the simple-minded way then of course
we'll get the senescence sooner so as I
mentioned this is a highly highly
regulated system so in principle there's
two kinds of things that can regulate a
genetic and non-genetic so let's turn
first to genetics because it's more
simple to understand and we know what
causality is and so what do we know as
Hooda talked about so beautifully in the
case of red syndrome when you have
mutations you can map them and you
really know where you are and you can
make mouse models and you can know about
causality so there's a lot known now by
both in mouse model systems and also in
humans who are afflicted with a variety
of different sporadic occurrences in
which telomerase genes get mutated and
these are often again similar to what
who described for red syndrome often
haploinsufficiency
so we know it's as 50% gene dosage in
these cases and others course are
insufficiencies where you know the cause
is that the telomerase is down and only
down by 50% gene dosages enough to give
you first of all you can see telomeres
at quantitative Lee's you know much down
compared with say unaffected siblings of
these families which there are several
you know dozens known around the world
now right but we've see in all cases and
in the mouse models the reduced ability
of cells to replenish over the long term
and indeed that has a very clear disease
impact so we know the genetic pathway
here and the disease's are a very
interesting group are prominent among
them our immune system
you see pulmonary fibrosis you see liver
cirrhosis you see highly increased
frequencies of certain cancers and now
very recently it's showing up clearly
diabetes is in there too it's really a
very interesting group and you'll see
some interesting overlaps with what I
just showed you in terms of telomeres
shortness and common populations but
this is severe and this is rare so we
have the causality you know the lack of
the draw you know who you chose for your
parents or the unfortunate sporadic
mutations you know mutations occur right
and that leads to shorter telomeres and
that leads to the disease impacts so
that's really clear causality we're in
firm ground here so now what about the
general situation now work is being done
in various settings and as I told you
before that from that table you know we
know tilma shortness is associated with
disease but is it you know by product is
that a biomarker is it irrelevant so
what do we know well you can look at you
know snips in the populations this just
picks out one example where a couple of
populations have looked at and and the
bottom lines you can see telomerase in
this case collaboration RNA gene
component variants a couple of different
cohorts you can see some relationships
you know they're not huge but you can
see yes one of the snips is associated
with somewhat shorter telomeres than in
people who have you know the other snip
so you see such things but the effect
size is not huge and in this case there
was certainly no ability to relate that
particularly to disease incidence or or
frequencies or anything but you know
there are some effects of common slips
said there's something there a nice
example of this being detected was
recently published by a good now and
what they looked at was was they just
did by genome-wide Association studies
now not looking for telomerase mutation
just do you know my dissociations this
year they looked for common snips just
you know from the population at random
associated with tell me a shortness and
then they looked in case control studies
at disease in this case it was certain
cancers and what they found was that
this risk of that with the certain
a particular one that they look at they
found it was having an impact
it was clearly increasing bladder cancer
in this particular case this slip was
clearly associated with bladder cancer
and part of the effect was mediated
through telomeres shortness which you
could show by mediation analysis but not
only effect so it's a mixture so the
question is going to be you know in
general what how will this play out when
you see telomere shortness that's
genetically associated with common snips
how much of it will play out through the
telomere shortness in this case it was
clearly a portion of the effect was
mediated through telomere shortness but
by no means 100% of it far from it so so
that's the sort of thing that you can
ask about genetic situations here but
what about non-genetic situations and so
about ten years ago one of my colleagues
at UCSF
her name is Elissa EPEL and Elissa was
then a postdoctoral fellow and she came
to me and she came from a very different
world the world of clinical psychology
studying long-term physiological effects
of chronic psychological stress on
people she said what happens to
telomeres when you know when people are
under long-term stress and I said oh no
and so this began a series of marvelous
collaborations within and outside UCSF
and with a whole lot of groups of people
where now we're asking about what about
this particular really rather widespread
situation and its impact on telomere
maintenance and on diseases so chronic
stress the kind I'm talking about is is
not not the kind that most of us whine
about where we have a grant application
or something like that but um you know
we're stressed out from our exciting
jobs it's the kind of situation you know
we complain that we chose it no I think
it's very interesting and I'm not being
moralistic here because I'm trying to
understand this rather overused word
stress and what was meant in these
studies is a very different situation
which I'll just try and capture in
certain sorts of things which is the
situation is long drawn-out it's there
person has little or no control they
feel over the situation it's often
unpredictable they feel they do not have
resources to
you know there's a whole lot of things
that set it up in a way that is you know
often long-lasting and as I said quite
quite severe and in fact there's a good
literature which really links this kind
of stress defined in various ways and
I'm going to give you examples with very
common diseases and just one example is
cardiovascular disease with a very
robust large epidemiological studies
have linked this kind of chronic stress
that general kind you know with things
have really seen as threatening and and
so forth for long periods of time with
for example cardiovascular disease okay
so what we found in the first cohort we
looked at which was a cohort of mothers
and the controls in which their
biological child had a chronic disease
of one kind or another and she was the
primary care giver and she was under a
stress of which she perceived to varying
degrees and for which she had been under
the space for varying numbers of times
in this cohort numbers of years in this
cohort sorry but continuous long lasting
situation and this has been a well
studied kind of objective stress or and
so what we found was the telomerase in
the high stress individuals were lower
than in the most rate of so it was lower
than in the low stress people so they
have dampened telomerase which would
predict less good telomere maintenance
and indeed very statistically
significant shorter telomeres in this
group compared with the low stress
people so that was the first study and
what was particularly interesting was
that we also found that the number of
years the mother had been in this
situation after correcting for age and
many other parameters was are very much
related to the shortness of the
telomeres and so that really suggested
it was the stress that was causing it
because it was hard to imagine the other
way around what might mediate these
effects this fist comes in the brain and
then there's obviously physiological
effects and one one good candidate which
we're looking at is is stress hormones
because in the motile Amore's group
stress hormone levels were higher than
in the high telomerase group I won't
show you the data but just the same data
was for shorter telomere group versus
higher telomere group you know the same
relationship of stress hormones we know
that stress hormones such as cortisol
damped
telomerase action in immune system cells
and so so you know this is something we
can study the pathways up and we're
doing but this is just you know the
observation in in these individuals
because the idea is to find out well
what is actually going on in actual
human beings here quantitatively
speaking and now we were very reassured
when in a completely different cohort
who now with the cohort I mentioned
earlier who are much older women and
they're the primary caregiver for a
dementia family member
often their husband often somebody with
Alzheimer's but by no means that's the
only kind of dementia and so again a
long-term situation fitting those sort
of fairly toxic sort of stress
situations I mentioned and so again we
saw this sort of similar kind of
relationship of I didn't show you in
this form but shortness of telomeres was
related to perceived stress here now
I'll show you the raw data because I
really want to emphasize so this scatter
here you know these are real people
there's a lot of complexity here but the
relationships quantitatively the things
that are you know starting to hold out
over and over again in these different
settings that I'll now go through a bit
so this is the perceived stress
situation which looks that sort of
encapsulates about a month of the
situation are some questions what is
that what is that month past month been
like so it's a kind of a sampling but
you could look at other kinds of
relationships that relate to stress
situations many of these such
individuals both with and without the
caregiver situation actually have eating
disorders which is distressed eating
patterns and this is not caloric
restriction but they attempt to diet and
and after correcting for BMI and also
two other possible confounds again we
saw a clear relationship between the
degree of severity which is along the x
axis of this distressed eating pattern
by a quite well-established
questionnaires sort of scoring system
and the telomere length and I always
like to say you can lie on the
questionnaires but you can't lie about
your telomere length okay and and I
think that's very important but it also
hides a rather important point which I
am really getting from this and that is
that the perception of the stress is
important it is what's happening in the
person's mind that is an important
parameter
right and so that's one this is for the
postmenopausal women we found just the
same situation for the caregiver mother
cohort and their controls as well here's
another interesting one pessimism in
which people tend over the long term to
see potential situations as having
threat in them and so this questionnaire
is buried in a whole lot of other
questions you know so the you can't
really tell what the intent of the
questionnaire is but the whole idea is
to try to you know sort of it buried in
the questions are the peasant pessimism
related ones the hope is to try to not
have people sort of gain the system too
much but regardless you know again we
saw this sort of relationship and again
I want to emphasize the scatter here you
know this is not absolute by any means
but it's statistical again again in the
same direction we've looked in a group
of with own walcker wits and colleagues
in the de secretary Department at UCS
who looked in the group of people who
did and didn't have depression
depression and then it is a relatively
young age match and matched in every
other parameter accepting income control
and that you can have and so this
actually is relating to physiological
issues and this is the oxidative stress
ratio measured by this f2 ISO protein
vitamin C ratio and what you see again
right across that both groups is a
relationship between their oxidative
stress and telomere shortness and so so
again we're seeing times with what
looked like fairly macro sort of
physiological settings and we've seen
that and we saw that kind of
relationship in the caregiver mother
cohort as well and to the other cohort
we've seen this same kind of thing so
the depression didn't make much
difference for this but if you looked at
something else about the depression in
the depression group of this and it's a
small study but it was interesting
because this was the lifetime duration
of their depression it's corrected for
age but what you saw again was this it's
small in but it's quite intriguing
because it looks like the cumulative
effective stress may be related to the
telomere shortness so this is just a
very initial study but provocative I
would
now another very interesting thing
suggesting there may be long-term
effects of of things that happen to
people in their lives on telomere
maintenance came from this study which
we did with Thomas Nylund and others in
San Francisco in the VA and UCSF and so
basically this is cumulative exposure to
traumatic events in childhood and they
categorized it by the number of
categories of trauma that you know
severe things have happened to in
childhood so if we looked at people with
0 or 1 there was very little effect on
telomere maintenance and these are now
young to middle-aged adults but people
who had more you started to see a
relationship right across the entire
sample with the people who had more
severe trauma exposures and this has
been seen in another completely
independent cohort by others too so it's
not just this group and in fact
childhood trauma exposure of this kind
is a big risk factor for post-traumatic
stress disorder
and so all of these people actually in
this code what they're all the ones who
had the post-traumatic stress disorder
and so now if you just look to post
traumatic stress disorder people you
just saw this the same relationship so
the whole group had had this this is now
for the all the post traumatic stress
disorder people said it was unchanged so
basically it was in the setting of
post-traumatic stress disorder that we
were seeing these effects of multiple
trauma exposures and that was simply
because in the control group at this
point and we're now expanding the group
we didn't have in you know the normal
population such exposures are relatively
rare and we didn't have those but now
we'll expand that so in this combination
of settings post traumatic stress
disorder for which this is a high risk
for post traumatic stress disorder
of having large categories of childhood
traumas then we saw this relationship so
again in adults you're seeing what may
be a somewhat persistent effect you know
cause and effect is hard to sort out but
here you know we're just looking
quantitatively and so this and other
kinds of data I really think make us
think that there is some causality here
and we are seeing this and as I said in
multiple sort of cohorts and this is
being seen by others so now what about
the dynamics of teal
so everything I've told you is sort of
going downhill right but in fact the
idea of what happens with telomeres had
been previously based not on
longitudinal studies but on
cross-sectional studies and that's
everything I've shown you so far as
cross-sectional and what you saw was if
you looked at people over their ages you
saw a general trend down but with the
kind of scatter that I'd been showing
you in those scatter grams for these
various cohorts so a lot of scatter but
a general trend down so people said Oh
your telomeres inevitably shortening but
was that true so it was based entirely
on this cross sectional studies it
wasn't true and in fact this nice study
here exemplifies that not only is it not
true but it might be interesting so here
this is a cohort fits the MacArthur
aging study in the Boston area these
were highly functional high cognitive
function people at the beginning
followed out for about 11 years and
their telomere length just average
telomere length was measured in their
white blood cells at the beginning at a
slight and two and a half years later
okay and then we see what happens is
that the people who survived who don't
die a cardiovascular disease related
death are much better in terms of their
risk for such death if their telomeres
are maintained or even lengthened and
about 1/3 to 1/4 of the cohort do this
and then the others whose telomeres
shortened in this period this early
period they have a much higher risk of
death and this kind of thing is starting
to show up in another study we've been
doing where telomere shortening over a
period of time is being clearly related
to death in elderly individuals so in
this case just as one example but there
are now more beginning to emerge
telomere length change predicted
cardiovascular disease mortality you
know this is a significant class of
mortalities so can it be shortened can
be shortening so I'd be alleviated and
so these studies are much more beginning
stages but interestingly the factors
over which one does have control such as
interestingly mega 3 fatty acids and of
the DHA EPA subtype interestingly were
related to tell me a shortening
in a study we did with colleagues at the
VA and UCSF what was looked at was the
degree of telomere shortening over a
five-year period in these individuals
who had relatively stable coronary
artery disease at least to begin with it
was stable and so they're divided into
quartiles of their level of omega-3
fatty acids in their roof through sites
and there so this is better and better
with regard to what's been known in
terms of good epidemiological
relationships between omega-3 levels and
cardiovascular progression and and risk
and so forth so having more is really
well based in terms of DHA and EPA at
least well based in epidemiological data
that says this is you know better for
cardiovascular disease risks and
situations and so what happened was that
progressively you saw that there was
progressively less and less average
telomere shortening so this is the fall
going down in the five years with this
parameter here and we're now
collaborating with people at Ohio State
University to doing randomized
prospective studies with feeding and
placebo to really ask was this causally
related to telomere maintenance or not
but this observational study was very
strong and even after correcting for all
sorts of different parameters which have
been related various ways to disease
risks or would be compounds will be
related to telomere shortness this
relationship between omega-3 fatty acid
level at baseline and where the
telomeres grew or not it was in a
substantial proportion of people they
grew in that five years so they grew
over the five years that omega-3 fatty
acid level turned out to be you know a
significant qualitative parameter and a
predictor of this so the change over
five years was predicted by omega-3
fatty acids independent of a lot of
other factors so again interesting
things where we can start to isolate
certain things but not to ignore the
fact that I'm sure a lot of these things
are acting fully in concert and so
combined effects are going to be very
critical
so another situation over which people
have control is the degree to which they
exercise and back in the same credit
cohort I mentioned before interestingly
enough if you looked at the
number of minutes of daily exercise that
people had it more and more buffered the
effect of stress on telomere shortness
and so as you did more exercise you
could basically wash out the effect of
telomere shortness that was associated
with stress and in a completely
different cohort this is now 251 healthy
women we've seen just the same thing in
terms of exercise bothering the effects
this time of childhood maltreatment of
the kind that I was telling you about
more in the post traumatic stress
disorder in their control studies and so
what we saw is while in sedentary
individuals there was a you know
significant effect of the association of
maltreatment with telomeres shortness
such an effect in the active group and
this was reasonable moderate to vigorous
activity per day there was less
maltreatment associated telomere
shortening so again looks like a
malleable kind of parameter here so back
to where we to finish up you know where
where are we in all of this okay well
the question had been did chronic stress
affect telomeres and we think there's
now a reasonably good data from various
cohorts that give us a good sense that
this this arrows is real now we also
know as I said in multiple studies
around the world that short telomeres
are related to disease impact of a
variety of kinds which I'm sure there
are genetic and environmental and other
influence interactions but we can say
you know certainly has some non genetic
component as well so now the question
just as I did for the genetic you know
common genetic variant question was you
know how much of it is mediated through
telomeres and how much of it is not
mediated through telomeres and I think
that now is going to be a very
interesting kind of a question because
what we can do is try to understand this
aspect at least of the causality of the
disease processes because I think that
way we can get a handle on there you
know on
various aspects of what might be
thinking someone can do to intervene in
in them but while we're seeing is this
really rather common pattern and even
though the effect sizes are such that
they average out live in large groups
this is you know this is the issue that
we have to think about you know as we
look at populations and human health in
general and perhaps I'll lead in
somewhat to our next speaker bye-bye you
know this concept that we want to look
at populations and see what sorts of
things do impact on health and things
that are things that we had some control
over environmental and lifestyle
behavioral we have you know limited
control genetically but we know there
are things that things that we do have
some control potentially open very
interesting questions how does one
utilize that information because what we
see is that these converge on telomeres
and their maintenance and that in turn
converges on what we see as risks for
you know a variety of the common
age-related diseases so I'm going to
finish with a sort of conceptual thing
because I've tried to draw this together
and and I thought of this way of trying
to bring all this together so so you
know we think we go through life right
and there's a lot of cumulative effects
of what goes on in life but you can sort
of think of there's a road that might
sort of bifurcate too you know putting
us on a road more toward disease risks
or a fork of the road more towards
health right so that go through life
this is more and more what we'll see
lives trending towards and we know that
there can be net telomere loss and we're
seeing there can be the converse
telomere upkeep so what do we know that
influences these kinds of things well
obviously genes right so that's going to
be the luck of the draw you know choose
your parents wisely right and then and
then there's going to be things that
I'll just summarize them very briefly
you know things we've seen that really
do have impact on disease risks and
these things we know from clinical
studies clearly have disease risk
implications and we're seeing they're
associated with telomere loss and
sorting this out is going to be very
important you know what does bystander
what is causal how do we mechanistically
understand this and then the good news
sort of is on the other side this fork
of the road
we've seen education and this is some
studies that are emerging but education
is starting to emerges as a good one for
Telemachus and exercise as I've given
you a couple of examples and stress
reduction and I haven't shown you those
but there's a few pilot studies that
suggest interventions under stress
reduction do have this effect and
they're sort of deflecting you into this
side of the fork in the road so we
clearly have a long way to go but I
think what we're seeing is it is a kind
of overall picture where if we step back
it looks as if this long-term
maintenance of selves for which telomere
maintenance is emerging is
quantitatively one factor in humans it's
not the only one clearly but it is a
factor when we can quantify and it makes
very good mechanistic sense as to what
might be going on in terms of the
underlying mechanisms and etiology even
of some of these long-term chronic
diseases which are going to be such a
big factor as we as we you know merge
further and further into the century and
and look at the demographics world
worldwide thank you